yeah this movie's a little obscure i
totally get that special
circumstances though here's the story
this dude has a youtube channel
and he did something that i i would
probably usually consider creepy but
when i interacted with him he didn't
seem like he was creepy so i didn't
really find it creepy i hope he's not
creepy i don't think he's creepy
anyhow dude made a youtube video where
he sits there
for about 12 hours and says my name
100 000 times
1000 i was i was just like
all right man what do you want me to
watch and reveal i'll do that didn't
know what else to do i guess that's what
i do and i'm kind of speechless so he
picked turbo kid i watched the trailer i
was like all right well i'm intrigued
so here we go also please don't make
videos where you sit there and say my
name a hundred thousand times thinking i
will review something that you want me
to review i'm always
going through the comment section i see
your comments i'm always getting ideas
some of them come from there i just
don't want an influx of fans saying my
name a hundred thousand times
sitting there for 12 hours and getting
blood clots i don't want you to get
blood clots i'm amazed he didn't get
blood clots so
here we go this was the movie he
requested
[Music]
turbo kid from the get-go you can tell
this movie's super low budget it takes
place in this
post-apocalyptic future i've seen people
compare this to
stranger things meets this or that
stranger thinks probably because it has
a young person they're on an adventure
but to me it kind of
felt like zombieland with no zombies
meets mad max i mean this young dude has
rules that help him survive there's the
older badass who knows how to navigate
this world also
very mad max the thing it has in common
with stranger things the most i think is
the fact that it's throwing back to the
past in an ironic pop culture kind of
way though it wasn't made back then it's
like the year is 1997
and here are a lot of 80s throwbacks
including but not limited to the
soundtrack which actually really does
work
well with the movie but you know what i
mean it has that ironic thrown back to
the 80s kind of vibe though it was made
in 2015. anyhow it's a low budget
action super gory comedy adventure yeah
it's strange stuff
but there's an endearing quality to it i
mean what the movie lacks in budget it
does make up for an imagination when the
gore happens it's always like whoa
it's shocking yet still also kind of
cheesy not even kind of it's so
over the top it's the stylistic choice
they obviously made they're not trying
to go for realistic here but there's
also long stretches of just
scenes of dialogue and heart between
this dude and his new friend apple he
runs across this new friend her name is
apple she's really nice super sweet also
does crazy guys really well
it's funny because her eyes are actually
remarkably gorgeous now saying they're
not in the movie i'm just saying
when she wants to she could totally do
crazy eyes and the bad guy the overlord
the landlord in this post-apocalyptic
[ __ ] as michael ironside either the
entire budget went to michael ironside
or he just kind of did it as a favor i
don't know which but michael ironside's
amazingly over the top in the movie and
i keep
using words like that you know like oh
amazingly over the top and cheesy
which is why i feel like people either
love this movie or
don't i don't think people hate this
movie but there are people who are like
not for me but i totally get but i dug
it i don't know just like it's this
weird imaginative world where if i made
a movie
i would hope i would make a movie like
this it's just weird quirky and
[ __ ] up bloody violent what else do i
want in the world these are the kind of
movies my friends and i
wanted to make when we were young this
movie would actually make a really sweet
video game that's what it feels like it
feels like i'm watching a video game
when i was watching this movie i mean
the kid gets this attire that's
from a comic book that he found and he
has this thing that goes on his arm that
just
blows people up i could totally see some
pixel bass retro bass
modern game some side scroller astro boy
type adventure only is turbo kit they
should totally do that movie feels a
little choppy at points sometimes i was
like all right let's
we just saw some pretty exciting gory
[ __ ] let's get back to it sometimes it
drags on a little bit i don't know if
they were like well we're trying to
we're trying to have heart man these are
character moments or they're like we're
trying to stretch that budget the
violence
that costs money i don't know but i
could have gotten for more of it which
means when it goes down you do
appreciate it there is that but you
don't want the audience to feel like
they're just
waiting until it happens again i didn't
always feel like that it's a touching
story between these two but sometimes it
felt like that i suppose
a lot of my complaints in the movie come
from the fact that they probably didn't
have the budget to push it you know so i
i have to
keep that in mind like i could have gone
for seeing more of the world so yeah but
we're kind of limited on locations here
but this is a movie that if you like the
unconventional quirky weird ridiculous
those movies that look like they're
going for the pocket of cult classic
this is one of those things
it's not for everyone sure and what i'm
going to say next i don't know
how the filmmakers feel about it i don't
know this movie probably be a perfect
time
if you're high yeah and now it's the
party i mean that in the nicest way
possible too it just
is what clicked with me so turbo kid
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you